[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record where we talk about
whatever we
want you know what someone said i
thought it was really funny
that my new hairstyle is like an antenna
and it's
dow i'm downloading from the ether like
all this information
and that's why i have these spurts of
sometimes interesting philosophical
things to say
they're nice that's very nicely i think
it looks like a firework previous
antenna then because you've always done
this
i had a boner oh now that your hair is
growing out it's the same texture and
color as mine
really i can't wait till it gets longer
we could do the same hairstyles
and then we could really be twins that's
true maybe i'll do mine like yours
you should we should come out with a new
style and i could have an antenna too
and if we get the same messages
then you'll know that's true fact yep
i call that the possibility trying to
grow out his hair too maybe he should do
it like this
what's the end style for kids these days
like the in hair
long hair don't care do kids even know
because they're not even seeing each
other anymore i got social media that's
for sure
but do i look like a joke like a joke do
i look like a joke
i'm not a joke i do kids even have style
though because
yeah you don't remember i'll be seeing
some no i mean i don't think there's a
difference between
like high school style and adult style
no more because i'll be on
tick-tock and i'm all like oh no no no i
cannot look at her
this way because i don't know what age
she is and some
well well put in some not it's like you
can't tell because they have a woman's
body like
they look like athletic all this stuff
and i'm just like
i just cannot go in that realm that's
true i mean because
girls get their periods at different
times and like there's a like after you
get your period and you go through
puberty
like from like 14 to like
27 like you can't sometimes you can't
tell the age
before i could tell because of the way
they dressed
and then like the way that they didn't
know how to do makeup yeah i've seen one
tick tocks of
of of girls that are like our age
like 30s and they end up doing like
this is 15 like a green screen thing and
it's like this girl doing this really
cute seductive like that's the other
thing she looks like a grown-ass woman
because we didn't have youtube tutorials
growing up so like
you could really tell if you were 15
because you're trying to do your
sister's makeup or your cousin's makeup
and it looks like all [ __ ] up yeah so
then that same video they'll start
posting pictures of themselves at 15
like this is 15. it's like all grumpy
and like awkward
but now because of social media you can
see other 15 year olds and everyone's so
advanced because they're watching like
21 year olds like that or whatever and
like they get makeup techniques down by
their time they're eight years old
and so yeah they look also we watch love
island and they say their ages at the
beginning of the show it's like
i'm from uh wales wales and i'm 21
and the person looks like 30. yeah
because they have so many like
fillers and like everybody
what do you guys think is harder to tell
like uh
a 15 year old girl from a 25 year old
girl or a 15 year old guy from a 25 year
old guy
easy guys don't guys guys mature way
later i think guys
bodies you can tell too like usually
a high school kid has a certain body
type oh yeah
whereas like structure it's difficult
because like
like especially in asian girls right
like they could be in their 20s or 30s
and they look like they're eight or
something
not yeah you can't tell
asian girls are 21 until they're 70.
yeah yeah and for girls we have makeup
we have like bras that like give you
cleavage like we just have so many
different things
we don't really have stuff that like we
can't put on like fake
five o'clock shadow to make it i'm sure
guys do i think
i've seen meant like grown men to just
wear makeup like just to
wear makeup look like more older and
have more masculine features
i don't know about that but there was
this one guy at this car this car
this like body shop thing it's actually
what i was looking for for your truck
and i went to this one like auto
mechanic thing
why can't i get it right anyway he was
wearing he was wearing like
full coverage makeup what and
he was like trying to hide from the
police he was
i don't know it looked like he had acne
he was trying to hide it
but he kind of went above and beyond
though where it looked like he did his
eyebrows and it was just like it was a
lot and he was
he was not very good at it no no i mean
like
i wouldn't think that he was like into
makeup he was more like
like just i think that's dope i want i
want to see more guys wearing makeup
really yeah
like in human history yeah so much
egyptians yeah stuff dude we wear powder
wigs and [ __ ]
yeah next stars wear eyeliner all the
time you don't think i look alive
uh you could fill in your eyebrows a
little bit more yeah you could like even
out your skin
talk about someone else's face you
[ __ ] ask me
do you think i could rock some eyeliner
he already has eyeliner he looks perfect
dory
but then he he wears something is he
wearing it
or is it yeah when he's i'm sure game of
thrones he's wearing
yeah it's waterproof new technology i
think it'd be cool if guys did wear
makeup but i think i'm too old-school
personally myself like
for me to like find that attractive dude
you plug them in your [ __ ] shoulders
you don't like johnny you don't like the
90s
hair bands and like motley crew and all
those boys that wore makeup all day yeah
pirates of the caribbean
like the k-pop boy guys that like wear
blush and stuff dude when we did school
plays
we got to wear makeup and it was sick
because i had acne for sure and
it was like one night scars it was like
well thank you it was a lot of work a
lot of time a lot of accutane
but um that night was the only night i
felt like i could be in any light
setting and not think about it the whole
when you wore makeup when i wore makeup
um during
drama and then after we got to all go to
denny's afterward and i'm not thinking
about the fluorescent lights and [ __ ]
i i think that i would wear it if it
wasn't so
damn uncomfortable yeah it's because
you're not used to it i barely like
lotion and the one you guys were like
for jk [ __ ] is like the cheapest [ __ ]
i barely like 99 store makeup yeah it's
really nasty
and when we put the eye eyelashes on
it's so heavy i couldn't even open up my
eyes
i agree even when i wear them i'm like
why do we wear them
if you guys are like oh honey give me a
kiss like oh hold on a second
i don't mind i'm like finally you get it
for real chicks
chicks don't like to do that though
you'll ruin them mind you don't want to
put on makeup yeah they'll be like don't
kiss me oh i thought you were taking it
off you're
you're adding it i'm a dude and now i'm
i'm a 20 25 dude
and i wear makeup oh we don't put it on
before we kiss oh you don't
no we take it off before we go yeah you
get a [ __ ] napkin and you go we don't
want it to get all over our
faces you're gonna do it accurately bart
shows how much i know unless we're
trying to mark our territory that
lipstick
oh yeah and then you pee on them yeah
then we peed them a little bit
and then the other girl's coming like oh
he's taking him he's taking you up [ __ ]
oh he smells like pee that's not a good
guy you want to go with
smells like piss yeah we did that then
you can't catch a surfer because he's
always in water
we'll put blood on him on his clothes
that [ __ ] doesn't come he's probably
always peeing on himself too
i know yeah i didn't even think of that
dude bikers bro
if it's cold and you have a wetsuit on
yeah and you pee and it's just pee going
all over your back and you're naked
it's like a peepee sponge it is what
about bikers
well like tour de france people legit
piss and [ __ ] themselves
and like those long distant runners they
just [ __ ] all over their legs
it's all about the time oh no my
ex-boyfriend's dad
he will work on the telephone poles you
know you go up there like doing
the linemen i i don't know really what
they do phoneme but
uh but he would there was bags that they
peed in
so they had these bags that were
attached to them and they just have to
they had to pee they had they just peed
in this bag because they can't climb
back down
i don't know about that maybe there's a
different bag for that because it takes
too long for the crane to go through
yeah and then he goes out and takes a
piss and comes back
dude yeah you don't know where that
crane is maybe he's a different
guy you want to take a [ __ ] like that
like just like really high up and then
just
let it [ __ ] go where it may i bet
hunters do that
very liberating offering a tree yeah
i'm gonna try it for hours like on a
[ __ ] stand won't you like attract
people like animals insects i don't know
wait do they have trousers like a
cartoon where it's just buttons
[Laughter]
right yeah then you button it back up
like santa claus always wore those yeah
yeah yeah
i always thought about those buttons i'm
like isn't it uncomfortable when you
lay down and like the buttons like
digging into your back yeah there's two
of them
and they're big ones too i have a onesie
that has the buttons like that
is it comfy um do you use it do you [ __ ]
through the back no
no cause i don't know they they miss a
line to the butthole or maybe my butt's
too big but like
i don't know the flap is like above my
butthole so i'd have to like pull it
down
you don't like living life on the edge
no yeah how does it work because like
let's say you sit on the toilet but that
door's not
big enough and it doesn't cover your nut
door so you gotta pee
yeah but you could take a dump but you
can't pee you're supposed to
you're supposed to pull your dick
underneath like where your butt would be
pops out of it maybe
yeah well on the boy ones they have the
buttons in the front too
oh pop your dick out of that if you're
like on the [ __ ] edge take a [ __ ] at
your friend's house through those
through that screen door thing uh
because wait you [ __ ] up
what room in the [ __ ] house the the
one the closest to them
the one closest that's on the [ __ ]
head through a screen door what do you
mean go through the
back flap i'm talking about for the past
five minutes the buttons because then if
you [ __ ] up
everyone's gonna knock many times i've
looked on the age on the edge
on the age uh when i'm drunk i
think i'm really good at peeing with
rompers and like pulling it to the side
nope it just completely wets my entire
robber
the same thing happens when you try like
moving panties to the side when you're
trying to have sex it's just like
it's still there it might as well take
them off but before i have sex though i
gotta like relax
oh yeah and then so this video is
brought to you by phil
bill they sent me um a box and i've been
taking a few drops of the cbd oil to
relax
and it's pretty nice like i think before
i start something
different right because every time i
transition a task like let's say
i'm at i'm doing something high energy
i'm working i'm on a phone call i'm
doing zoom meetings all that
and sometimes to relax from that it
takes me
hours like i just don't know why but
they're too wound up yeah and then i'm
just like in my head
zoom meetings are exciting if you're
talking about exciting things big time
like it can fire you up right
so yeah i just started to try like cbd
oil and stuff
and and it actually chills me out in a
couple of minutes
you just get like a like a oil thingy
and it's kind of like a poo poo dropper
and you go and you put it on your tongue
and then
you kind of just start chilling you feel
like your whole body just relaxes like
every muscle is just like instead of
being like this it just goes ah
yeah yeah and but i like to drink it
with tea something warm
and then it's kind of meditative too
because
i just wait for it to kind of kick in
and then i can transition into like
winding down for the day like way faster
so what used to take me like hours now
takes me a couple minutes
wow so if you guys are trying to wind
down and have the best
part of your day towards the end or in
the beginning uh you become a member
today by going to feels.com
off the record and that's f e a l s dot
com slash off the record and you get
50 off damn your first order with
free shipping so that's an insane deal
50 off that's half off
that's f e a l s dot com slash off to
record become a member and get 50
automatically taking off your first
order with free shipping
get the feels get the feels
that reminds me oh do you guys
he didn't he wasn't even around during
that time i just talked about my
youtuber boyfriend
yep oh that was him yeah yeah yeah yeah
crazy when we used to have asked the
fields and kids i know it was crazy
because we would ask
uh nikki about steve but you didn't know
him yeah
at all we didn't know like so what was
the footage of him
well my first image the first time i
ever saw steve was at tim's roast
yeah but i already knew of the stories
so the minute i saw steve i was like oh
so you're the guy
where she likes to uh where he likes to
get where nikki likes to get banged and
then the balls are slapping her in the
vagina
so that's my first like image when i saw
steve for me it was um
i seen this guy i don't know where
and then it's because i used to like
watching his bang bus
pranks he would get guys to be in the
bank bus and he's like you ready for the
porn stars and then these buff guys come
in and that [ __ ] was so
funny to me those guys were dumped yeah
and then then i made the connection i
was like
oh hold on what the hell he does comedy
like that
let's bring him on yeah yeah but
cause i was talking about you being like
a comedian youtuber and that's when
david still was like yeah
right keep this coming and then he met
you and he's like oh yeah yeah
critical david what did you hear about
us hey dude that's what i [ __ ]
that's all anybody cares about with
youtube it's like oh yeah you do comedy
yeah because comedy is so like
fluid on youtube it's like you know it
doesn't necessarily mean you did
actual comedy it was a lot of wigs no
okay so i heard about you guys through
her i hadn't
i've i had heard of joe malia for some
reason i don't know i never heard of
anything else about
jk i had just heard of joe malia before
and i knew you i thought your first and
last name was joe o'malley
i didn't [ __ ] know is he still my
phone did this chosen
my phone as joe malia too i just thought
his name was joe molly i didn't [ __ ]
know
and then uh because he just didn't know
his last name so i was easier
yeah i don't think he disclosed it yet
so it's not jojo but i met you guys
called
in this room that was the first time i
had seen you guys and met you guys when
we invited you oh
the road all right you're right right
now really true i was like i'm so bad at
names
that at the rose we did meet and [ __ ]
but i was seeing so many [ __ ] people
that night
um i'm so bad at names it takes me very
important takes no it takes me twice it
overlaps with people i was talking to
all the people in the roast as i'm
saying it happens all right
listen he's very important twice to to
remember somebody's name right
so i remember we were in this room and
actually you guys busted me in the video
but i played it off a little bit
but in the video i was like because you
had all said your names with me real
quickly
but it was such a [ __ ] much
information that
during the video was like well bart you
know whatever and i was i was in this
direction thinking it was david i think
oh and then and then geo's like he's
burped and i was like i know that i am
[ __ ] around
but i didn't i called you out yeah you
did it
but it was great it was that was like it
sounds like you that was me not actually
[ __ ] knowing but that's funny i
didn't know anyone's names either i
thought julia owned the channel
and then i was like okay i know her name
because she reached out to me and she
owns the channel
when people think that yeah i'm just
kind of like a
dumb guy on the side i love it i didn't
think you were a dumb no no no i'm
saying you but
a lot of people think what i remembered
about you was you had the best t-shirt
like i felt like we could get along
because you had
uh bill clinton with american flag on
fire
and like he had a poster today eagle in
the background and i was like that's a
funny shirt
i know i gotta get some more of those
posters
that's one of my favorite artists i
couldn't and i couldn't remember who was
geo
between you know what he's doing them
too
[Music]
she might have been bart no i didn't
even know the name bart
david thought geo was a man yeah i heard
that story
you have to say it right
okay i know but it's funnier to explain
it that way
no here we were talking via text
not because he met me in person i know
but that that imagery is much funnier
it is but i have to come in he's talking
about robust man
i know a tall man with large breasts
well he didn't
yeah he didn't have large breasts then
that's why it was more convincing that
she was a man
now in order for me to remember who
their names i would think like bart
buff b oh oh yeah buff is bart bart is
buff
joe is the other guy joe jokes
jokes dude i had a teacher who first day
of school he
was a science teacher he learned
everyone's names in the
like first 10 minutes dude and then like
the second month he forgot everyone's
name
i wish i can do that if i know that's
the game at the beginning
that we're all going to memorize names
you could do that i can remember
everybody's names yeah great memory if
that's if i know going into it but if
it's just like we're at a function and i
suddenly meet a bunch of people i was
not prepared to remember everybody's
name wow you're so important
very important i could meet someone and
i really
i really want to memorize their name
because i know how much it means to
people like later on when you just oh
it's whatever right
so after i meet them and i go home in a
month in the car i'll literally like try
to memorize and i'll say their name over
and over
i do that too and i forget immediately
yeah and the next time i meet them i'm
like
[ __ ] i did the [ __ ] homework too
dude remember that [ __ ] gathering
[ __ ] happened
it was us three and then i would always
have to whisper in your ear who the [ __ ]
that person was
and my favorite way is i always try to i
find someone i know and i introduce them
so like let's say i forget frank's name
i'm like oh hey this is my wife geo
geo and then that way she goes hey i'm
geo then he goes he's frank and i'm like
frank i love this guy that is the worst
[ __ ] makes the [ __ ] best
when you're somewhere and you're
standing with somebody whose name you
don't know and then your wife comes up
and you're and then you're like but
that's the easiest cause you just go
oh hey this is my wife nikki and then i
go i'm nikki yeah
if they understand the game if they
understand it it might be on the same
page if i wasn't in my head stressing
the [ __ ] out i would have clever ideas
like what do you do instead i'm like
i just [ __ ] sometimes i'm like hey
man yeah he's just rude
i'm like why don't you introduce me to
that person yeah and then she's like
roasting yourself
i know and i'm like i don't know their
names cause they know like once you
introduce it oh she goes why don't you
introduce me you go uh
i want to what's your name honestly
that's how bad it is that's how bad it
feels why don't you just go say like
i know you but i forgot your name yeah
because only you can do that
i do that i do that all the time i do
that if i haven't met them a thousand
times because that's
that's the part where it's like it's
gone past the point okay
right now we have neighbors in our new
community and
like for some reason casey and i can
only remember like the guy neighbors
because they're the ones that are more
talkative like and but then the wives
sometimes they'll come out and then like
we'll we'll talk about the kids or
whatever but then casey will look at me
like do you remember the wife's name i'm
like no do you remember her name
that's why you create nicknames and then
flower lady but then now it's been so
long
and we see them so many times but it's
just so awkward to bring up their name
every time because i think i brought it
up like the first like two
i have a trick for it i have a trick for
it sure because i need it too okay so
okay this is what you do so if there's
been too many times this is my trick
um i just called them a random name and
they're like oops sorry that's not your
name
you just remind me so much of my friend
jennifer that like who's
i'm sorry what's your name again i
always get you guys
jennifer wait no sorry your name's not
jennifer oh you you got me so much of my
friend jennifer what's your name again
and they're like
they're like they're like my dead
mother's name is jennifer
that sounds like a guy trying to pick up
a girl at the bar that sucks it's my
only go-to because i'm like
[ __ ] you're cute it's been like eight
times it was like
i can't pretend i just give up i just
don't ever
ever even include names ever i just go
with it so literally the point that i'm
at with my neighbors right now
i'm like hey girl we have this neighbor
that lives across the street from us
i know the the husband and the wife's
name the kid's name
i don't know but the problem is every
time taika goes out
hey taika taika how you doing i'm like
hey buddy so when this kid comes out
like
hey
[ __ ] what's this like how's your boy
doing and the longer it's been
the more i can't say what was your kid's
name again because we've been living
together for a year now that's so
funny it's so stupid but it all
it's horrible no because see it's gonna
find a trick the more i actually
interact with somebody and engage with
them
it's so easy to remember their names
right like jk crew i got their names
down immediately
because you're hanging out a lot right
but [ __ ] like
somebody i worked at maker studios with
10 years ago and they're like hey man
remember
maker i'm like
sure like it's a nightmare just say you
got amnesia
that works i like that i'll be like
hello are you my mother i'm sorry i
don't know your name i'm sorry
no the thing that i thought of for that
kid situation is like
uh well i guess now it's different with
the pandemic you don't really have
gatherings but
if it was normal time you're like oh i'm
throwing like a barbecue whatever i
wanted to send an invite like how do you
spell your kid's name again
i used to do that like john you don't
know how to spell john i mean people
spell
different when or
a good j.o.h that's a girl yeah
i don't know how to spell jeff
you